addressing russian ambassadors gathered
in moscow vladimir putin distanced
himself from events unfolding in eastern
ukraine he also implied the new
administration in kiev is making a grave
mistake
unfortunately president poroshenko
decided to resume his military operation
when i say we i mean both myself and my
european colleagues
we were not able to convince him that
the road to sustainable solid and
lasting peace cannot lead through war
publicly at least moscow had been
pushing for an extension to the
ukrainian government ceasefire before it
expired putin also offered poroshenko to
let ukraine monitor border checkpoints
but poroshenko said the separatists had
only used the ceasefire to regroup
we will liberate our land
the decision not to extend the ceasefire
is our response to terrorists rebels and
marauders to all those who terrorize
civilians
the government's 10-day long ceasefire
in eastern ukraine was never really
effective fighting continued and both
sides blamed each other for the violence
on the weekend the ukrainian security
service arrested men it suspects of
trying to bomb a railway track near
kharkiv
this and attacks on government forces
has made ukrainians question separatists
commitment to peace talks
germany's foreign minister has expressed
disappointment at the end of the
ukrainian ceasefire
but he told a dw media event he hopes
that more talks will produce results in
the coming days
i think it would be good to build on the
limited dialogue that's taken place so
far between russian and ukrainian
authorities
if we were to continue and to intensify
those efforts then perhaps joint border
controls would result
that would prevent weapons and fighters
crossing over ukraine's eastern border
but for now diplomacy has been sidelined
amid more violence in eastern ukraine